Let's look at an example. A lot of times where you
find yourself in a situation, where you need to get creative, you're
probably going to need to scrape data from a website. In
my experience, this is most often the case when the data is
provided by a government agency of some kind, or maybe a
small grasssroots organization. In this case, the example I woild like to
look at is from the US bureau of transportation statistics. So,
imagine we have a need for among other things to get statistics
on how many flights individual carriers have. To and from
the airports in the United States. Okay, now this particular
page provides us with a way of getting at that
type of flight data. That is, how many flights say Virgin
Atlantic has into and out of Boston Logan Airport. But
in order to get it we have to go through a
lot of work and a lot of manual effort if
we want to pull all the data for all the carriers.
So this is a great example of a situation where we would
problematically deal with this problem. Okay now I've got this zoomed in
big enough so that we can see what's on the page and
as a result the layer is falling apart a little bit so bear
with that. So, let's take a look at how we would use
this site. Now right now, this is providing for us, the number of
domestic and international flights for all carriers, US and foreign, with a
destination of any airport. So, if I want to get just the data
for Virgin America, and all of the
flights for Virgin into Logan Airport in Boston,
I can make those selections and click submit. And here we have just that data.